[Applause]
they were running for their lives
frantically trying to keep their
families together amid the mayhem and
gunfire desperately handing over their
toddlers to soldiers and strangers
scrambling to get away from the firing
and shelling even as they fled
many have spent days under fire trapped
in their homes until they realized it
was run or die with the russians getting
closer
in my city russia's soldiers
killing people
urban on the outskirts of the capital is
being relentlessly shelled
and there's no escape not even for the
civilians you can see at the top of your
picture running with their cases to get
away
this is an entirely residential area
two children and their mother were
killed outright but this area is filled
with families utterly powerless against
this attacking army
the bombed bridge connecting open with
kiev is now a target for the russian
troops
and those trying to escape came under
fire several times
the ukrainian soldiers tried to shoot
down drones pinpointing the positions of
the fleeing families
those rushing to get out are the most
vulnerable who felt too nervous to try
to escape until now when there was no
other option
but this route used by hundreds 24 hours
earlier is now desperately dangerous
and the attackers are showing no mercy
well that was the loudest we've heard
yeah we better go out now um there's a
lot of incoming now and it's getting a
lot closer
the russian military is pushing forward
towards the capital and is taking ground
killing and injuring as they do so
and a lot of the casualties are
civilians hurt by shrapnel and mortars
fired in heavily populated built up
areas
attacking civilians and non-combatants
is an international war crime
and multiple families gave us first-hand
accounts many who only just survived
themselves
i was helping people evacuate neither
bridge and i wanted to give some
chocolate to a child and there was a
family of four there but only the mother
survived a child about 13 or 15 was hit
by two bits of shrapnel in the head and
died immediately
all three of them died
putin says he's not attacking civilians
what would you say to that
they're shelling civilians directly she
tells us not any military place or
object they're shooting at schools on
hospitals they're shooting everywhere
all the time for the last three days
that's what they've come from
they show us the damage done to their
home and the residential buildings
around them and in their street
when we got out of our home i saw five
six shells maybe every building was
destroyed and had been hit
the stream of people fleeing are
traumatized but many are also angry and
full of despair
putin's a war criminal she says the
antichrist you've been waiting for him
now you've got him
families have been torn apart in the
chaos they ran into urban from a village
outside before escaping urpin 2 and
they've left elderly relatives behind
all houses are in fire and that's all
that they can see how much destruction
is there that you could see in the in
the town center
i think oh oh destroyed there is nothing
to help
there is nothing to build or defend
there is nothing
i came here and i left my parents to die
she tells us and i told my husband
you've got to go back and bring them
here because i can't just leave them to
die
but in amongst this suffering and trauma
there are small glimpses of hope her 81
year old mother and father are found
and the family is reunited
how could i live without you she says
there is incredible heartache in fear
but also an astonishing defiance about
these people
alex crawford sky news in open